hello everyone
welcome to the next video about
character education today's video is
about don't break the chain challenge
we're going to explain the concepts
explain how it works and then we'll talk
about the process methodology and the
results
what is a habit a habit is a routine or
behavior that is repeated regularly and
tends to occur subconsciously the
american journal of psychology defines a
habit from the standpoint of psychology
as a more or less fixed way of thinking
willing or feeling acquired through
previous repetition of a mental
experience
how do habits form
according to experts with psychology
today habits form when new behaviors
become automatic and are enacted with
minimum conscious awareness that's
because the behavioral patterns we
repeat most often are literally attached
in our neural pathways
it turns out that every habit starts
with a psychological pattern called a
habit loop which is a three-part process
first there's a cue or a trigger that
tells your brain to go into automatic
mode and let a behavior unfold that's
what we think about when we think about
habits
think about something it took you a
really long time to learn like how to
parallel park at first parallel parking
was difficult and you had to devote a
lot of mental energy to it but after you
grew comfortable with parallel parking
it became much easier almost habitual
you could say parallel parking gambling
exercising brushing your teeth and every
other habit forming activity all follow
the same behavioral and neurological
patterns says new york times business
writer charles duhigg
then there's the routine which is the
behavior itself the third step is the
reward something that your brain likes
that helps it remember the habit loop in
the future
neuroscientists have traced our
habit-making behaviors to a part of the
brain called the basal ganglia
decisions meanwhile are made in a
different part of the brain called the
prefrontal cortex
in fact the brain starts working less
and less the brain can almost completely
shut down and this is a real advantage
because it means you have all of this
mental activity you can devote to
something else that's why it's easy
while driving or parallel parking let's
say to completely focus on something
else like the radio or a conversation
you're having
you can do these complex behaviors
without being mentally aware of it all
and that's because of the capacity of
our basal ganglia to take a behavior and
turn it into an automatic routine
studies have shown that people will
perform automatic behaviors like pulling
out of the driveway or brushing tee the
same way every single time if they're in
the same environment but if they take a
vacation it's likely that the behavior
will change
it's also a great reason why changing a
habit on a vacation is one of the proven
most successful ways to do it if you
want to quit smoking you should stop
smoking while you're on a vacation
because all of your old cues and all of
your old rewards aren't there anymore
so you have this ability to form a new
pattern and hopefully be able to carry
it over into your life in order to gain
good habits and to break the old ones
you need to have a goal the goal helps
you focus on one task at a time having a
goal helps you focus and be productive
at the same time
what is a goal a goal is an idea of the
future or desired result that a person
or group of people envision plan and
commit to achieve people endeavor to
reach goals within a finite time by
setting deadlines why is important to
have a goal setting goals helps trigger
new behaviors helps guides your focus
and helps you sustain that momentum in
life goals also help align your focus
and promote a sense of self mastery in
the end you can manage what you don't
measure and you can't improve upon
something that you don't properly manage
how the habits connect with our goal
habits are algorithms operating in the
background that power our lives
good habits help us reach our goals more
effectively and efficiently bad ones
makes things harder or prevent success
entirely habits powerfully influence our
automatic behavior
anytime i get bored with a book or i
would like change of pace i just switch
to a different one a great way to do
this is to always read one fiction book
and one non-fiction book at the same
time
12.
get a reading partner you can also get a
reading partner to help you keep
yourself accountable to your reading
goals this can be a friend of yours a
significant other or a colleague you can
start reading the same book with your
reading partner and then discuss it as
you read or once you both finish reading
the book let's finish the video with the
famous quote laziness is nothing more
than the habit of resting before you get
tired if you like this video share and
subscribe with your friends and
colleagues
thank you for watching